c'est l'heure du journal de l'Afrique
soyez les bienvenus sur France 24 à la
une ce soir les réactions à Goma au
lendemain de la signature d'un
cessez-le-feu dans l'est de la
République démocratique du Congo un
accord signal Luanda où se tenait un
mini sommet pour la paix en RDC la
population reste très sceptique et ne
semble pas convaincue par ce cesser le
feu des centaines de personnes ont
défilé à Goma pour dire leur ras-le-bol
reportage de nos équipes à suivre et
puis nous serons également en direct
avec le porte-parole adjoint du
gouvernement rwandais Alain moukoura
Linda ce sera dans quelques instants la
condamnation à mort de 49 personnes en
Algérie une condamnation pour le
lynchage d'un jeune homme accusé à tort
de pyromanie un drame survenu en août
2021 lors d'incendie criminels en
Kabylie cette peine de mort sera commuée
en réclusion à perpétuité en raison d'un
moratoire sur les exécutions
et puis Coupe du monde de football les
résultats du jour pour les équipes
africaines le Ghana a tenu tête au
Portugal mais à tout de même concédé une
défaite trois buts à deux défaites
également pour le Cameroun face à la
Suisse un but à zéro les réactions à
Yaoundé à la fin de ce jour
moins de 24 heures après l'annonce d'un
Cécile feux dans l'est de la République
démocratique du Congo la population de
Goma était dans la rue des centaines de
personnes ont défilé pour exprimer leur
ras-le-bol des violences il reste très
prudent quant à la tenue de ce cesser le
feu reportage à Goma de juste un kabomba
et Aurélie bazarra qui manga
à bout des centaines de manifestants
sont descendus dans les rues de Goma
mégaphone en main
ces jeunes donnent de la voix pour
interpeller la communauté internationale
complice selon eux de la situation dans
l'est du pays alors comme l'entente
nationale est en train de jouer de quoi
de mesure aujourd'hui lui demandant à la
communauté nationale
et de dire le Rwanda de
faire sortir ses forces notamment les 23
l'armée rwandaise l'armée ougandaise et
tous ses alliés dans notre terre encadré
par la police les manifestants se sont
dirigés vers les consulats de la France
et de la Grande-Bretagne vous allez
réceptionner c'est mémorando pour les
transférer à qui dedo en cessez le feu
immédiat dès vendredi 18h a été décidé à
l'issue d'un mini sommet qui s'est tenu
mercredi à Luanda le document prévoit
également le retrait du M23 des zones
occupées et sont désarmement en
territoire congolais des décisions qui
sont loin de convaincre de la société
civile du Nord qui vous en avons déjà
marre parce que il y a tant d'accord que
notre pays a déjà signé il y a tant de
dialogue que nous avons déjà réalisé
mais jusqu'aujourd'hui nous continuons à
fuir nous restons dans des cas sans
assistance aucune nous avons besoin de
la paix de la sécurité nous sommes un
peuple nous avons droit à la paix et à
la sécurité les gouver donc les la
communauté internationale doit cesser
avec cette hypocrisie autre point de
crispation la résolution du Conseil de
sécurité des Nations unies qui prévoit
une notification sur l'achat d'armes en
RDC les manifestants dénoncent un
embargo qui empêche le pays de se
défendre face au M23 mardi le Conseil de
sécurité des Nations unies s'était dit
près à réexaminé cette résolution
et justement sachez que le M23 qui a
réagi ce soir estime ne pas être
vraiment concerné par cet accord voilà
pour la dernière information alors hier
nous interrogions Patrick Muya ministre
congolais de la communication ce soir
nous donnons la parole à Alain
moukoura Linda pardon porte-parole
adjoint du gouvernement rwandais bonsoir
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous ce soir
alors tout d'abord pourquoi le président
Paul Kagame était-il à absent à Luanda
il devait s'y rendre il s'est finalement
fait remplacer par son ministre des
Affaires étrangères Vincent Biruta noté
que toutes les parties étaient
représentées par leur président l'Angola
le Burundi la RDC cette absence fait
dire à certains que le Rwanda n'est pas
vraiment ne sent pas vraiment concernés
n'est pas déterminée à oeuvrer pour la
paix dans l'Est de la RDC que leur
répondez-vous
je pense que
plus important et que le Rwanda ait été
à la Réunion c'est ça le plus important
peu importe la personne qui a représenté
le pays l'essentiel est que celui qui
était là à capacité et la compétence et
représenter le président de
notre antenne je cite le M23 et
représenté par le Rwanda disons les
choses telles qu'elles sont enfin de
citation votre pays le Rwanda s'est-il
engagé hier à sommet le M23 d'arrêter
les hostilités dans l'est de la
République démocratique du Congo
premièrement je ne suis pas d'accord le
Rwanda n'est pas d'accord avec cette
affirmation c'est son interprétation et
ça n'engage que lui ce qui est sûr c'est
que le Rwanda est satisfait de la
résolution qui a été
prise hier et même s'il y a rien de
nouveau en effet par rapport aux
résolutions de nairobie de Luanda et
dernièrement au Burundi ce sont toujours
les mêmes résolutions les mêmes
décisions qui ont été prises en revanche
la résolution a montré encore une fois
l'incapacité totale et donc l'échec du
gouvernement congolais a instauré la
sécurité à l'est du pays et son manque
de volonté politique d'appliquer les
résolutions
intérieures voilà la raison pour
laquelle le gouvernement congolais ou
son porte-parole se permet de dire que
le Rwanda était là au nom du M23 c'est
faux le Rwanda ne représente pas le 23
et le Rwanda n'est pas le porte-parole
du M23 c'est ce genre d'insertion qui
ont toujours conduit à ce que les
résolutions prises ne soient pas
appliquées parce que on est en train de
de mélanger les choses selon la
résolution
c'est un sécurité la persistance dans à
l'Est de la RDC de ces forces de négatif
de ces terroristes constituent une
menace pour la paix la sécurité et la
stabilité de la région or le manque de
sécurité à l'est de de la RDC cause
l'insécurité dans les pays limitrophes
c'est pour cela qu'on a vu les armées
ougandaises et burundaises combattre sur
le territoire congolais les retabara et
hadf et ça c'est la résolution qui le
dit dans notre côté en se concerne le
Rwanda c'est au nom de voir comment le
gouvernement congolais on met
volontairement la collaboration de ses
forces armées les phares d'essai élèves
et d'autres groupes rebelles c'est
toujours la résolution qui parle de ces
groupes en conclusion tous ces groupes
armés opérant sur le territoire Soro la
résolution doivent immédiatement déposer
les armes et entamer leur
le Rwanda que compte faire le Rwanda
pour convaincre ces groupes armés à
déposer les armes notamment le M23 on
l'a vu ce soir le porte-parole du M23
qui estime que son mouvement rebelle
n'est n'est pas vraiment concerné par
cet accord comme que compte faire le
Rwanda quel rôle peut jouer le Rwanda
dans ces cas-là puisque vous dites que
vous n'êtes pas derrière le M23
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez faire quel est
votre rôle dans cet accord de
cessez-le-feu
sécurité et sur sa sécurité le Rwanda ne
peut pas transiger peu importe qui est
le MP3 ou pas ce qui importe pour le
Rwanda c'est la sécurité du Rwanda et
des et des Rwandais donc M23 comme les
autres mouvements doivent respecter la
résolution qui a été prise hier et on a
donné un
chemin à suivre si ce mouvement ne
respecte pas la résolution qui a été
prise il y a des décisions qui seront
plus en conséquence le Rwanda n'est pas
ici pour parler au nom du MP3 le Rwanda
ce qu'il importe c'est ça sécurité alors
vous ne pouvez pas non plus nier que il
y a eu un rapport de l'ONU qui accuse le
Rwanda et l'armée rwandaise d'avoir
soutenu le M23 il y a eu aussi une
pression internationale qui s'est
exercée ces dernières semaines sur le
Rwanda
le département d'État américain qui a
aussi demandé à toutes les parties de
d'arrêter de soutenir les milices dans
l'est de la République démocratique du
Congo il y a d'ailleurs une rencontre
entre Anthony blinken et le ministre
rwandais des Affaires étrangères Biruta
est-ce que vous ne pensez pas que cette
crise dans l'est de la République
démocratique du Congo est en train
d'isoler le Rwanda non madame parce que
vous parlez de du rapport des
experts des Nations Unies et vous
émettez et les gouvernement congolais on
met de dire que ce rapport parle
également que comme je viens de le dire
de la collaboration entre les phares
d'essai et F de l'air c'est noté noir
sur blanc et on se voit on se demande
pourquoi et dans la presse
internationale et ailleurs on en parle
jamais de ce fait de notre côté les
affirmations des différentes
personnalités gouvernement ou
institution qui parle sciemment d'une
partie du problème tout en tout en
ignorant
la globalité ou en considérant une
partie du problème
une autre partie ils ne participe pas à
la restauration
de la paix à la à en RDC aujourd'hui le
problème est connu il faut combattre
tous les mouvements sans exception et
non seulement deux ou trois mouvements
d'anciens gouvernement ou un
représentant ou une personnalité parle
d'une seule partie
ça démontre que on n'a pas vraiment
envie de résoudre ce problème et cela a
été le cas pendant 20 30 ans aujourd'hui
il est temps qu'on reconnaisse ce qui se
passe réellement sur le terrain il faut
combattre tous les mouvements sans
exception sinon la paix ne sera jamais
restaurée merci beaucoup en tout cas à
un mot courant Linda d'avoir répondu à
notre question à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes porte parole
adjoint du gouvernement rwandais merci
d'avoir été avec nous ce soir je
rappelle cette dernière information le
porte-parole du M23 dit que son
mouvement n'est pas vraiment concerné
par ce cet accord de cessez-le-feu qui a
été signé hier
souvenez-vous c'était en août 2021 des
incendies criminels ont détruit près de
90 000 hectares en Kabylie dans le nord
de l'Algérie le bilan officiel fait état
de 124 morts un autre drame s'est ajouté
à ces incendies le lynchage d'un homme
Jamel bensmail ajouter à accusé à tort
pardon de pyromanie sa mise à mort
violente avait suscité l'indignation
dans tout le pays aujourd'hui un
tribunal a condamné à mort 49 personnes
pour se crier méthanager
la justice algérienne et les services de
sécurité ont enquêté pendant plus d'un
an s'appuyant sur des témoignages et des
vidéos postées sur les réseaux sociaux
où l'on assiste au lynchage de Jamel
bensmail et le verdict est sans appel la
peine de mort pour 49 personnes jugées
coupables de ce meurtre des accusés qui
verront leur peine commu et en réclusion
à perpétuité en raison d'un moratoire
sur les exécutions les accusés étaient
poursuivis notamment pour actes
terroristes et subversif contre l'État
et l'unité nationale et homicides
volontaires avec préméditation 28 autres
accusés poursuivis dans le cadre de
cette affaire ont été condamnés à des
peines allant de 2 à 10 ans de prison et
17 ont été acquittés
août 2021 alors que la Kabylie est en
proie à désincendies meurtriers des
civils se portent volontaires pour
contenir les feux dans la région parmi
eux Djamel ben Smail un artiste de 38
ans qui va connaître une fin tragique il
est soupçonné d'être un pyromane à
l'origine des incendies et décide de se
rendre aux autorités pour prouver son
innocence mais Djamel ben Smail et
rapidement extirpé du fourgon de police
par la foule frappé avant d'être brûlé
vif pendant que des jeunes photographies
la scène les selfies macarbrison de les
réseaux sociaux ils seront par la suite
compilés par les internautes pour que ce
lynchage ne reste pas impuni dans tout
le pays la population est indignée les
autorités s'engagent à traquer les
responsables
si quelqu'un porte atteinte à l'unité
nationale
j'utiliserai tous les moyens pour lui
faire payer cher
certains individus impliqués dans le
lynchage ont été livrés à la police par
leur propre famille le père de la
victime nous Réding ben Smail la lui
était érigée en héros national après
avoir appelé au calme et à la fraternité
entre Algérie
h la Fédération internationale pour les
droits humains publient un nouveau
rapport ce jeudi sur les violations
commises contre des populations civiles
au centre du Mali attaquent exécution
sommaire violences sexuelles le document
qui s'appuie sur une centaine de
reportages de témoins et de victimes
recueillies entre 2021 et 2022 mais en
avant la hausse des attaques contre les
civils des attaques commises par toutes
les parties au conflit écoutez maître
drissat Traoré secrétaire général de la
FIDH au micro de Sarah Sakho notre
correspondante à Dakar au centre du Mali
beaucoup de violations des droits de
l'homme sont commis aussi bien par les
groupes djihadistes les forces
d'autodéfense et l'armée malienne et
ainsi que par le groupe Wagner et donc
il y a des anciens des mers des
assassinats de sécurité des enlèvements
et des viols et donc ce rapport montre
les violations s'accroissent au centre
du Mali et malheureusement
malheureusement
les procédures judiciaires n'avancent
pas les victimes sont obligées de
cohabiter avec les bureaux et cela en
cela aggrave leur situation et nous
pensons en tout cas que les autorités
malins et ce sont nos recommandations va
prendre les mesures nécessaires pour que
la c'est les moyens pour que les
procédures judiciaires avancent pour que
les auteurs soient recherchés d'être
arrêtés et juger et condamner nous
espérons également que la communauté
internationale va continuer à soutenir
les efforts du Mali mais surtout
également à dénoncer tous les travers
qui peut être commis par les autorités
malaires y compris les forces armées du
Mali
et puis on continue à suivre les équipes
africaines pour cette Coupe du Monde
2022 à l'affiche aujourd'hui le Cameroun
face à la Suisse les Lions Indomptables
ce sont inclinés face aux Suisses un but
à zéro et vous vous en doutez les
supporters étaient très déçus
écoutez-les au micro de notre
correspondant à Yaoundé Marseille à mon
cours
je suis un homme blessé je suis je suis
mal actuellement c'est que je ne peux
que dire mes frères en oignon c'est que
tout ce qu'ils ont pu faire tout à
l'heure là ils essaient de rectifier
tout ça le deuxième match avec les
hommes jusqu'à et pourquoi parce que le
Lion ne désespère jamais le lion n'est
jamais abattu puisqu'il est le roi de la
forêt à lui la victoire pour toujours je
vais donc dire en tant que lion que
quand le lion est blessé il devient
farouche et cette férocité vous allez le
voir lors des prochaines matchs
et puis la défaite du Ghana contre le
Portugal même si les coéquipiers de
Cristiano Ronaldo ont souffert face au
Black Stars les Portugais se sont
imposés difficilement trois buts à deux
voilà c'est la fin de journal de
l'Afrique restez avec nous dans quelques
instants la suite de Paris direct avec
Audrey racine
[Musique]